[Music]
this chaos in here
the fun of moon night is getting
introduced to a new superhero in a new
world
it's a real legitimate character study i
can't tell the difference
between my waking life
and dreams
moon knight is a spectacular character's
got an incredibly unique visual look
our job was to kind of put a lens on the
things that had the most uh dramatic
juice and ultimately take the mental
health aspect incredibly seriously
i am
stephen
the way we're tackling the story we
learn about steven and then learn about
mark what's wrong with you mark
why did you call me mark and they're the
same person
[Music]
the tone is like fight club meets
indiana jones it's a bit dark at times
to tie it into something so vast and
supernatural it's amazing
thank you
every aspect of this show
has a duality and we've shifted the
paradigm
for me what's really exciting is that
it's totally unpredictable
[Music]
i can't tell the difference
between my waking life
embrace it
you